dennis Kozlowski is the former CEO of
tyco international Tyco International
began as a small New Hampshire company
it would it's a conglomerate of hundreds
of companies and koslowski was very
successful as a CEO he grew the company
significantly over the decade that he
was the CEO and by the time he ended his
career there in 2002 the company had
250,000 employees worldwide in more than
a hundred countries in annual revenue of
forty billion dollars so it was a huge
global multinational corporation
Kozlowski's career didn't end the way
that you might expect for someone who
had such great success in 2002 he was
indicted for sales tax evasion charges
by the Manhattan district attorney for
some artwork that was shipped into the
city so he was fired well immediately
after he was fired the Tyco board
decided to do an internal investigation
and they hired a high-profile attorney
named David Boies to complete that
investigation of the compensation and
spending of tyco executives and even
though koslowski was gone his actions
were part of the investigation when
David Boies and his team completed this
internal investigation they found that
type that kozlowski had received
compensation from the company that was
not authorized and that led to the
indictment later in 2002 of causal of
kozlowski and CFO marks warts and
Tycho's general counsel at the time I
mean they mark bell Nick and the three
of them were indicted for malfeasance at
the head of tyco koslowski was
compensated generously by the Tyco Board
of Directors over the years he was CEO
he was making in some years more than
million dollars a year it's so quite a
large salary one of the largest salaries
among CEOs at that time he was known for
a pretty lavish lifestyle large homes
and many places in the country he threw
a huge birthday party for his wife at
the time a two-million-dollar birthday
party on the italian island of sardinia
which made the news and there was video
of this very garish roman orgy themed a
birthday party he flew Jimmy Buffett
over to play at the party it cost a
quarter million dollars and it's true
that dennis Kozlowski did approve the
purchase of a six thousand dollars
shower curtain not specifically that he
didn't handpick it he didn't even know
it existed until he went to trial what
happened is he hired a decorator who
decorated an apartment in part of that
you know her choices was the six
thousand dollars shower curtain which to
this day he has never seen and never
used and and would never have purchased
himself he said Kozlowski was convicted
of state criminal charges in a state
court and sent to a state prison a hard
course new york state prison not a not a
club fed like so many other you know
white-collar criminals almost almost all
maybe even all of the other corporate
scandals if you look at them everyone
who was prosecuted was prosecuted by
federal prosecutors not state and they
go to federal prisons which you
sometimes hear called Club fed you know
they're they're nicer prisons than state
prisons I think a lot of people believe
that he had a you know luxurious eight
years in a in a country club with tennis
courts that's simply not the case the
prison is is scary and and even just
going in as a visitor is daunting he
just wrapped up his eight and a third
years which is a hundred months
of imprisonment the battle he's going to
have is overcoming this this image that
has been created of him as this really
bad guy you know this thief pig you know
criminal who you know stole 100 million
dollars from the company that he ran you
know that's that's tough to overcome so
that's that's what lies ahead for him
for the immediate future certainly